[Music]
so espen we're gonna play
a little game
where the bishops and knights
alternate being bishops
and uh and knights so
let's say i move this knight then it's
then it's uh now a bishop and uh i
move it again
uh let's say here
uh now next move it will be a knight
against and it's the same with my yeah
obviously the same with with your uh
this is completely new to me of course
have you played it a lot no i've
actually very recently uh learned it
so now
now i tricked you a little bit because
now i'm taking this pawn and it's
undefended because this is now
a knight
but this is a
bishop now this is a bishop yeah so i
can do the same yeah you can do the same
and this is uh this is now a knight so
i'm taking your queen
and this is a knight as well so i can
take your queen yeah
so this is uh
yeah now it's with uh exchange and now
i'm taking this because this is now
um
this is now
a night
so i didn't try to
[Music]
no no no
no you cannot do that because
i took well i i took it like a bishop
but now
it's uh it's a knight okay so i'm you're
in check i have to move my kingdom no
you cannot you cannot move it here
because it's still
it's still a bishop so it controls it
controls this square and
and you're in check so
that's the fastest checkmate
it really tricked me there yeah
the end